c'est Gérard bonjour bonjour tel que
promis chose due chose promise chose due
vous annoncez la baisse d'impôts est-ce
que la baisse d'impôts est financée par
de l'endettement supplémentaire pour le
Québec c'est-à-dire qu'on a pris une
décision équilibrée on devait on avait
une responsabilité de donner des
nouvelles cibles de dettes pour le
Québec à long terme et puis on a choisi
que ce sera en fonction de la dette net
qui la mesure utilisée par l'OCDE les
autres provinces nous sommes à 37 ans et
demi pour cent
on cible 30% d'ici 15 ans donc 7 et demi
0.5% par année si on n'avait pas fait la
baisse d'impôts on aurait pu atteindre
30% en 10 ans on va le faire en 15 ans
c'est vraiment raisonnable c'est un les
versements au fond du générations vont
continuer à croire vont atteindre 5
milliards en 37 38 je pense qu'on a
trouvé le bon équilibre mais c'est une
baisse d'impôt qui est financée par de
l'endettement c'est une belle mais quand
vous dites de l'endettement on continue
la poursuite de la réduction de
l'endettement alors c'est important de
le dire un peu cette année par rapport
au PIB puis elle va baisser ensuite
mais on a eu une ajustement aux normes
comptables en vertu des immobilisations
et donc il faut regarder l'ensemble 37
et demi 30% dans 15 ans qui avait pas eu
de belles impôts 30% dans 10 ans et ça
en effet aussi quand on regarde puis je
pense que vous l'avez entendu puis vous
l'avez expliqué on a l'impression que
c'est les gens qui gagnent plus d'argent
qui vont profiter des baisses d'impôts
mais les gens qui font pas d'argent qui
font peu d'argent qui sont démunis dans
la vie qui n'ont pas de baisse d'impôts
ne profitent pas de la bête mais on fait
autre chose et c'est important la baisse
d'impôts est pour les 4.6 millions de
québecois qui pètent l'impôt elle est
permanente et elle est dynamique c'est à
dire que vous avez un niveau de revenus
aujourd'hui vous pouvez avoir un niveau
plus élevé dans deux ans dans trois ans
et chaque année vous bénéficierez de la
baisse d'impôts pour les gens qui ne
paient pas d'impôts par exemple les
aînés de plus de 70 ans à faible revenu
on a amené un nouveau crédit d'impôts de
2000$ à la mise à jour en 2023 au Québec
on a une mesure qui est très
progressiste le programme de revenus de
base qui bonifie bonifie les prestations
pour les gens qui reçoivent la
Solidarité sociale depuis depuis plus de
60 mois donc on a d'autres mesures qui
rien à aider les gens qui ne paient pas
je comprends quelqu'un qui fait 20 000
par année c'était écrit dans votre
budget vite de l'art de baisse d'impôts
c'est normal que à toute proportion
gardée la baisse d'impôts de 100 dollars
à 30000 dollars et plus importantes en
proportion de ce que vous payez de
l'impôt qu'à 60 000 dollars est-ce que
vous ne venez pas affaiblir le fond des
générations qui est un fond pour réduire
la dette à long terme on parle toujours
d'équité intergénérationnel parce que
vous pigez 5 minutes vous prenez 5
milliards pour rembourser de la dette
cette année vous coupez 40% des revenus
à peu près sur deux ans vous avez raison
40% des revenus à peu près pour baisser
les impôts il y avait des revenus dédiés
qui allaient au fond des générations qui
ne seront plus au fond des générations
est-ce qu'on vient pas politiser le fond
des générations fragiliser le fond
contraire on a trouvé le bon équilibre
le fond de génération a été créé en 2006
600 millions de contribution
cette année ce sera deux points 4
milliards deux points 8 en 202728 5
milliards en 37 38 le fort génération va
continuer à augmenter là ce qui se
passait c'est qu'il a augmenté trop vite
les versements étaient trop gros en
proportion de des efforts qu'on doit
faire on a des missions de l'État on a
des gestes à faire et là c'est un
équilibre on a choisi de réduire le seul
objectif du fond de génération en vertu
de la loi c'est réduire la dette alors
c'est un équilibre on a choisi de
réduire la dette moins vite pour baisser
les impôts mais est-ce que c'est un
projet de société est-ce que c'est un
plan de développement de l'économie je
regarde vos croissance vos prévisions de
croissance dans les prochaines années là
c'est faible 06 cette année on s'entend
que 2023 est difficile 1,4 1,6 1,5 1,4%
croissance du produit potentiel de
l'économie québécoise c'est un point 5 %
et nous on veut l'amener à 2% vous me
dites ça oui mais c'est un travail à
long terme ça fait cinq ans je vous dis
ça puis on a fermé les corps de richesse
avec l'Ontario mesuré par le Pays-Bas le
PIB par habitant de 3%. alors on fait
des progrès la baisse d'impôts stimuler
l'économie augmenter le niveau de
l'économie de points 3%. donc dès que
2024 le niveau là
le niveau de l'économie va être point 3
va augmenter l'offre de travail de
points 4% l'élasticité de l'offre de
travail
l'équivalent de 16000 emplois en complet
mais est-ce qu'on n'attend pas davantage
une politique sur la productivité sur
l'efficacité une politique industrielle
pour répondre à l'administration Biden
on fait tout ça on s'attaque on a cinq
secteurs stratégiques au Québec on les
aide avec
le fiscal le crédit d'impôt aujourd'hui
congé fiscal pour grands projets
d'investissement l'amortissement
accéléré ensuite il y a direct le
travail qui est fait chez Investissement
Québec le fond de développement
économique ensuite il y a le Conseil
l'aide aux entreprises pour ce numériser
se transformer tout ça est fait
conjointement on aura besoin pour amener
le Québec à un autre niveau de vraiment
de pousser la productivité du Québec et
c'est là-dessus contraire et on n'a pas
le choix parce qu'on a le vieillissement
de la population et quand on regarde les
projections notamment le goût en effet
des projections on s'en va vers des
disciples structurels dans 10 à 15 ans
si on atteint pas les objectifs c'est à
dire de productivité et de
d'augmentation du niveau de la richesse
de déficit structurel à long terme donc
il y a pas de problème en 2035 le
vieillissement de la population
c'est maintenant le plus
le sommet là va être autour de
et donc on va avoir les moyens
pour chaque unité de production dans le
futur point 8 devient viendra de la
productivité point 2 de la croissance de
l'emploi pour l'emploi dans le budget il
y a plusieurs choses il y a les
modifications au régime des rentes de la
régionalisation de l'immigration il y a
la baisse d'impôts c'est trois leviers
pour accroître l'offre de travail pour
les entreprises les zones d'innovation
le congé fiscal pour grands projets
d'investissement il y a plusieurs choses
est-ce que les prochaines années seront
des années de restriction ou de rigueur
budgétaire je vous dis ça parce que je
regarde au niveau de croissance des
dépenses en deux et trois pour cent
c'est pas très élevé
la moyenne les revenus et les dépenses
sont arrimés sur l'horizon du corps
financier à 3% revenu dépenses c'est un
très bel équilibre et en santé 3,6%
l'année prochaine 3,3 % pour l'éducation
en fait là il faut faire attention parce
que c'est pas juste les taux de
croissance c'est pas compris vos
chiffres non c'est le niveau des
dépassés avec la covid le niveau des
dépenses a augmenté significativement
alors faut regarder le niveau de
dépenses pas juste le taux de croissance
et
en fait si on enlève les dépenses covid
la santé c'est un investissement de
7.6%. ça 23 24 7% mais trois points 6
l'année prochaine
l'année prochaine les budgets arrivent
ici c'est le budget 23 24 donc et là je
me suis au chef de l'année prochaine que
vous avez mis dans votre budget mais
c'est
vous vous me dites j'aime pas le niveau
de dépense que je vois en 24 25 mais en
24 25 il y aura l'opportunité de relever
le niveau de dépenses encore une fois ok
là en 23 24 on est à 7.6% de croissance
ensemble en santé c'est un effort majeur
parfait je m'occupe pas de ces chiffres
là dans ce cas-là dernier point
l'incertitude bancaire en ce moment oui
ça ne teigne pas vos chiffres ça vient
d'arriver là est-ce que ça vous inquiète
mais c'est à dire que faut prendre
regardez le système financier canadien
les institutions financières sont bien
financées elles sont bien réglementées
elles sont bien surveillées mais c'est
certain qu'au niveau global la politique
monétaire avec ce qui se passe dans le
milieu bancaire ça va restreindre le
crédit donc toute chose étant égale par
ailleurs pour un niveau de taux
d'intérêt donné la politique monétaire
va être plus efficace parce que le
crédit va être plus restreint par les
institutions financières
oui à moins qu'on ait moins de hausse de
tout parce qu'il y a une partie des
faits qui va se faire par les écarts de
crédit c'est ce que nous verrons
monsieur Gérard merci merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI